FOR TRUMP.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO LAUREN FOX.
THE RETURNS ARE OUT IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN THEM?
>> Reporter: THERE'S A COUPLE
KEY TAKEAWAYS, ONE OF WHICH WE
HAD AN INDICATION OF GIVEN THAT
THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON TAXATION
PUT OUT A REPORT LAST WEEK, BUT
WE HAD NOW BEEN ABLE TO VERIFY
WITH THE UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS
THAT DONALD TRUMP PAID VERY
LITTLE IN TAXES IN SOME OF THE
FIRST YEARS OF HIS PRESIDENCY,
IN FACT IN 2016 AND 2017 JUST
$750 EACH OF THOSE YEARS IN
FEDERAL INCOME TAXES AND IN 2018
AND 2019 A BIT MORE, NEARLY --
MORE THAN $1 MILLION IN FEDERAL
INCOME TAXES THEN NOTHING IN
2020, THE LAST YEAR OF HIS
PRESIDENCY, ABBY, AND THAT HE
OFTEN USED PROJECTING LOSSES
FORWARD AS A WAY TO REDUCE HIS
TAX BILL.
WE ALSO ARE LEARNING A COUPLE OF
OTHER INTERESTING PIECES OF
INFORMATION.
ONE OF THEM JUST QUESTIONS AND
THIS WAS RAISED AGAIN BY THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON TAXATION'S
REPORT LAST WEEK ABOUT HOW TRUMP
USED HIS TAX PROCESS AND TAX
PAYING PROCESS TO POTENTIALLY
AVOID PAYING TAXES, ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WAS RAISED BY THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON TAXATION IS
THAT HE GOT A LARGE AMOUNT OF
INTEREST FROM LOANS THAT HE SAID
HE HAD GIVEN TO HIS CHILDREN AND
AT SOME POINTS THAT INTEREST MAY
HAVE BEEN EVEN MORE THAN WHAT
THE MARKET VALUE AT THE TIME WAS
AND THAT HAS RAISED SOME
QUESTIONS FOR THE JCT AND IT
RAISED SOME QUESTIONS FOR AN
ACCOUNTANT LOOKING OVER THESE
THAT CNN SPOKE WITH AS WELL AND
THAT'S INTERESTING THAT
SOMETHING POTENTIALLY FURTHER
DOWN THE LINE THAT POTENTIALLY
AUDITORS OR OTHER ACCOUNTANTS
COULD LOOK MORE DEEPLY AT.
THE OTHER QUESTION RAISED, IN
ONE INSTANCE IN THE AEROSPACE
LLC, THESE INCLUDED BUSINESS
ENTITIES HE CLAIMED THAT HE HAD
MADE $42,965 IN PROFIT.
THEN ON THE SAME TAX RETURN IN
THE 15I78 YEAR CLAIMED THAT HE
HAD IN EXPENSES $42,965, THE
SAME ACCOUNTANT THAT CNN TALKED
TO SAID IT WOULD BE ALMOST
STATISTICALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
THOSE TWO NUMBERS TO BE THE
EXACT SAME BUT IF YOU HAVE THOSE
TWO NUMBERS IN YOUR TAX RETURNS
THEN YOUR TAX BILL IS REDUCED,
RIGHT, SO THAT IS ANOTHER THING
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD BE LOOKED
AT.
THERE ARE SO MANY PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS, ABBY, HERE, IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LOCK TIME TO
PORE OVER ALL THIS INFORMATION.
BUT THOSE ARE JUST SOME INITIAL
FINDINGS.
OBVIOUSLY REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IN JUST A MATTER
OF DAYS.
THIS WAS REALLY ONE OF THE LAST
MOMENTS DEMOCRATS COULD TAKE IN
THIS STEP TO RELEASE THESE
RETURNS, ABBY.
>> ALL RIGHT, LAUREN FOX, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
>>> LET'S NOW BRING IN OUR TAX
EXPERT ED McCAFFERTY AND DAVID
KAY JOHNSON, THE AUTHOR OF "IT'S
EVEN WORSE THAN YOU THINK: WHAT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING TO AMERICA" AND
COMMENTATOR CHARLIE DENT.
ED, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
TRUMP HAS TRIED TO KEEP THESE
HIDDEN FOR MANY YEARS.
WHAT DO YOU SIGH IN THERE THAT
EXPLAINS WHY THIS IS AN ISSUE BY
ALL ACCOUNTS SOMETHING HE IS
VERY SENSITIVE ABOUT AND HAS
BEEN SINCE HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> SURE.
AND I THINK THE GOOD NEWS AT
THIS TIME OF YEAR MAYBE THIS IS
THE LAST TIME WE'LL HAVE TO BE
TALKING ABOUT TRUMP TAX RETURNS,
WHICH I'M SURE YOU'LL BE HAPPY
ABOUT AND OTHER CABLE NEWS
ANCHORS MIGHT BE HAPPY ABOUT.
A LOT OF DETAIL IN WHAT WE SAW
TODAY BUT I THINK THE BIG
PICTURE IS WE'VE ALREADY KNOWN,
WE'VE KNOWN IT FROM "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" REPORTING AND KNOWN
IT FROM THE REPORTING OF DAVID
CAY JOHNSTON WHO YOU'LL HEAR
FROM IN A MINUTE.
TRUMP IS A VERY BAD BUSINESSMAN,
HE LOSES MONEY.
HE LOST MONEY FROM THE CASINOS
TO THE GOLF CLUBS WITH VODKA AND
UNIVERSITY AND TRUMP STEAKS IN
BETWEEN.
HE LOSES MONEY, HE PAYS NO TAXES
MAINLY BECAUSE HE LOSES MOANING.
HE SOMETIMES MAKES MONEY LIKE
WHEN HE'S A REALITY TV SHOW STAR
BUT FOR THE MOST PART IN IS A
MAN WHO IS A POOR BUSINESSMAN
AND LOSES OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY.
HE GENERATES LOSSES FROM THAT.
HE PAYS NO TAXES LIKE A LOT OF
AMERICAN BILLIONAIRES HE PAYS NO
TAXES.
WE LEARNED THAT THE IRS DID
NOTHING REALLY SERIOUS TO
QUESTION OR CHALLENGE OR EVEN DO
THE MANDATORY AUDITS, SO I THINK
WE DON'T NECESSARILY SEE
ANYTHING NEW BUT I THINK IT'S
THE DOG THAT'S NOT BARKING, THE
TAXES THAT ARE NOT PAID, THE IRS
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE NOT
PURSUED AND IT'S CHARACTERISTIC
OF A TAX SYSTEM THAT'S BROKEN
AND AN IRS NOT UP TO THE TASK OF
AUDITING THE WEALTHIEST.
>> TO THAT POINT, A LOT OF WHAT
IS IN HERE IS LEGAL.
PEOPLE MAY NOT LIKE IT BUT IT'S
LEGAL BUT I DO WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT SOME POINTS THAT LAUREN
JUST RAISED.
THERE WERE SOME BIG QUESTION
MARKS.
THESE LOANS TO HIS CHILDREN AND
THE INTEREST THAT HE RECEIVED.
EXPENSES THAT EQUALED THE EXACT
SAME AMOUNT AS THE PROFIT THAT
HE FILED.
ARE THOSE RED FLAGS TO YOU?
>> OH, SURE, I MEAN THERE ARE
PLENTY OF RED FLAGS AND WE NOW
KNOW FROM THE MANHATTAN D.A.
INVESTIGATION THEY WERE ABLE TO
GET A CRIMINAL CONVICTION OF THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION FOR TAX
FRAUD.
THAT'S PRETTY RARE.
IT'S HARD TO GET A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION FOR TAX FRAUD.
SO LIKE HIS FATHER FRED, TRUMP
CONSISTENTLY PUSHES AGAINST THE
LINE OF PROPRIETARY AND OFTEN
GOES OVER IT.
THERE ARE MANY, MANY MORE THINGS
THAN THE FEW DETAILS YOUR
REPORTER MENTIONED, OVERVALUE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS.
PUTTING THE KIDS ON THE PAYROLL.
DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF WAS ON FRED
TRUMP'S PAYROLL.
HE WAS AN EXECUTIVE WHEN HE WAS
9 YEARS OLD IN HIS FATHER'S
COMPANY SO THIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR DECADES.
IT'S PRETTY STANDARD AND TRUMP
OFTEN TAKES IT OVER THE LINE
THEN, OF COURSE, NO
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE HE'S EVER
REALLY AUDITED EVEN WHEN THERE'S
AN IRS RULE THAT SAYS HE'S
SUPPOSED TO BE AUDITED.
>> RIGHT, HE WAS NOT.
>> WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
HE WAS PRESIDENT.
>> HE WAS NOT AUDITED FOR THE
FIRST TWO YEARS HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
DAVID, TO YOU, THIS MORNING
TRUMP RESPONDED SAYING THESE
RETURNS SHOW HOW, QUOTE, PROUDLY
SUCCESSFUL HE HAS BEEN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT THEY
SHOW?
>> OH, THEY DON'T SHOW HE'S
SUCCESSFUL AT ALL.
THEY CLEARLY SHOW THAT HE TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF EVERY LAWFUL METHOD
OF TAX AVOIDANCE INCLUDING ONES
HE LOBBIED CONGRESS FOR IN 1992
SUCCESSFULLY LOBBIED THEM FOR
THAT WERE ENORMOUSLY BENEFICIAL
TO HIM BUT ALSO SHOW AT A
MINIMUM 26 EXAMPLES OF WHERE
DONALD CROSSED THE LINE.
AND ENGAGED IN WHAT I BELIEVE
CAN BE PROSECUTED AS CRIMINAL
TAX FRAUD.
DONALD IN 1984 FILED TAX RETURNS
THAT SHOWED BUSINESSES -- A
BUSINESS WITH ZERO REVENUE AND
$600,000 OF EXPENSES WHILE THE
CITY OF NEW YORK AND THE STATE
OF NEW YORK AFTER TRIALS DONALD
DEMANDED THE JUDGES HELD THESE
WERE CIVIL TAX FRAUD.
WELL, THAT PUT HIM ON NOTICE HE
CAN'T DO THAT.
HE DID IT 26 TIMES OVER THE SIX
YEARS AND THAT IS POWERFUL
EVIDENCE OF CRIMINAL INTENT.
HE KNEW HE SHOULDN'T DO IT.
HE DID IT ANYWAY AND WHY DID HE
GET AWAY WITH IT?
WELL, BEING IN CONTROL OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, HE BLOCKED
THE TURNING OVER OF HIS TAX
RETURNS, HE BLOCKED THE AUDITS
THAT ARE REQUIRED BY LAW AND FOR
YEARS HE DIDN'T RECEIVE ANY
SERIOUS MENTION FROM THE IRS
AUDITORS.
>> CHARLIE, OVER TO YOU ON THE
POLITICAL END OF THIS.
TRUMP HIMSELF WHEN HE RAN FOR
PRESIDENT, HE WAS THE FIRST
PRESIDENT SINCE JIMMY CARTER TO
NOT RELEASE HIS TAX RETURNS BACK
IN 2016.
BUT REPUBLICANS INCLUDING THE
SOON-TO-BE CHAIRMAN OF THE WAYS
AND MEANS COMMITTEE, KEVIN
BRADY, SAY THIS IS GOING TO
CREATE A NEW PRECEDENT.
HE SAYS THAT IT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE RELEASE OF TAX RETURNS OF
PRIVATE CITIZENS, POLITICAL
ENEMY, BUSINESSES AND LABOR
LEADERS AND EVEN HE SAYS SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS REALLY A
NEW PRECEDENT FOR ALL OF THOSE
OTHER PEOPLE OR JUST FOR PEOPLE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT WHO IN THE
PAST HAVE ALREADY RELEASED THEIR
TAX RETURNS?
>> WELL, LET ME SAY I AGREE WITH
DAVID AND ED ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP'S TAX AVOIDANCE SCHEMES
THAT ARE REALLY REPREHENSIBLE
AND MAY BE CRIMINAL.
I DON'T KNOW BUT I ALSO AGREE
WITH KEVIN BRADY.
IF CONGRESS WANTS TO PASS A LAW
TO SAY THAT A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE MUST RELEASE HIS OR
HER TAX RETURNS AND PASS A LAW
TO DO SO, YES, DONALD TRUMP
VIOLATED THE NORMS AND THE
TRADITIONS OF RELEASING TAX
RETURNS, THAT'S HIS RIGHT.
NOW, I DON'T AGREE WITH IT BUT
THAT WAS HIS RIGHT BUT I DO FEAR
THAT THEY MAY BE WEAPONIZING THE
RELEASE OF TAX RETURNS WITH THIS
ACTION AND I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR CHAIRMAN NEAL BUT I
CAN SEE THE REPUBLICANS SAYING,
HOW ABOUT SAM BANKMAN-FRIED?
WOULDN'T WE LIKE TO KNOW WHAT HE
PAID IN TAX AFTER WHAT HE JUST
DID?
AND I CAN SEE REPUBLICANS SAYING
HOW ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN IN HIS
BUSINESS DEALINGS?
SHOULDN'T WE BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT?
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE?
TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS, I MEAN, I
DON'T KNOW BY REVEALING THIS TO
THE PUBLIC THE WAY THEY DID
WE'RE LEARNING ANYTHING THAT THE
AUTHORITIES DIDN'T ALREADY KNOW.
SO, AGAIN, I THINK THIS IS A
PRECEDENT AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL BE WEAPONIZED GOING
FORWARD.
>> BUT, CHARLIE, JUST TO PUSH
BACK ON THAT A LITTLE BIT, I
MEAN, HUNTER BIDEN ISN'T RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
ISN'T THERE A DIFFERENT STANDARD
FOR PRESIDENTS THAN THERE IS FOR
THE SON OF THE PRESIDENT, FOR
EXAMPLE?
>> BUT CONGRESS SHOULD PASS A
LAW THEN TO SAY THAT A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND/OR A
PRESIDENT HAS TO RELEASE TAX
RETURNS, PASS THE LAW TO DO IT.
JUST BECAUSE TRUMP VIOLATED THE
NORM HE DIDN'T VIOLATE THE LAW
IN THAT CASE.
HE MAY HAVE IN ALL THE OTHER
THINGS HE DID.
I'M NOT A DEFENDER ON DONALD
TRUMP OF MOST THINGS AND HAVE
BEEN CRITICAL OF HIM OVER THE
YEARS BUT I DO HAVE AN ISSUE --
WHAT WAS THE LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE
OF THIS?
LOOK, THE COMMITTEE WENT TO THE
IRS AND THEY SAID, OH, WE
HAVE -- THERE WAS -- THIS IS ALL
FOR A LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE.
I'M NOT SURE I'VE SEEN THAT.
THEY CAN REFORM THE PRESIDENTIAL
AUDIT PROCESS WITHOUT RELEASIN